[Music]
hello my name is Dominus Chief nursing
officer for England
welcome and thank you for joining us
today on the eve of the third
anniversary and when the World Health
Organization confirmed a global covid-19
pandemic
today we come together to honor and
reflect on the service of all Health and
Care staff during this pandemic
this year marks the 75th anniversary of
the NHS
and today we also made time just to
honor and recognize our Health and Care
staff for their incredible individual
contribution to the NHS over the last 75
years
my thanks going to NHS Charities
together which represents the network of
NHS Charities basically every NHS
Charleston Health Board across the UK
for arranging this moment of reflection
let's make reflect it is an opportunity
to acknowledge the impact the pandemic
has had on our lives and communities and
to remember those we have lost
the last three years have been extremely
challenging for colleagues to co-host
Health and Social care
as they said he have Beats for so many
Across the Nation
I am so grateful for and preferred of
the role that all nurse simply driftry
and other Healthcare staff have made my
thoughts are with every person who lost
someone in the pandemic and with all
those who it changed profoundly
while I've always known how remarkable
our Health and Care Professionals are
the pandemic was shot an even brighter
light on their extraordinary world
I know the pandemic has had a last
impact on our professions and others
it remains a challenging time
but support and solidarity from our
quantities can give us all stress out
and find
I personally have never been crowded to
be a nurse and he part of the incredible
work that you do
so today is about remembering Learners
who lost their lives during carbon 19
and only within the service and huge
contribution of Health and Care staff
during the pandemic and over the last 75
years
it is also a chance to pay tribute to
what it takes to be a healthcare worker
thank you all for being here today and
thank you for all you do
[Music]
you remember me
together
[Music]
the field
s
[Music]
of gold
I never made promises
[Music]
foreign
was when
moves
[Music]
when we walked in fields
just beautiful
I have to confess I was a little biased
when we started planning our service
because when that was suggested it is
one of my most favorite pieces of music
so thank you I'm now not fit to leave
the service because I'm sober
but that's going to be okay isn't it
because we bring our tears of sadness
and our tears of joy and thank you for
making that connection for us bless you
I'd like to add my welcome to Ruth's to
all of you joining here today at the
beautiful National Memorial Arboretum
and online
on the eve of the three years since the
pandemic began
and in the 75th year of our wonderful
National Health Service
Health and Care staff are the Beating
Heart of our health care System
and have been so throughout the 75-year
history of the NHS
today we remember the service and the
sacrifice of those staff who have lost
their lives in the pandemic and who have
given their lives in the service
throughout the history of the NHS
we're also very very mindful at the
ongoing pressures our staff patients and
their families continue to feel
today
they need even more than ever for us to
say thank you
and to please stand with us in
supporting you
it's fitting that we're here
and we now come
and just begin
to prepare ourselves from moments quiet
in a moment
but we're fitting that we're here at the
Arboretum
a place dedicated to remember who have
given so much in the service to our
nation
sadly across the world as we speak today
people continue to face unprecedented
Challenge and devastating loss
they too are very much in our hearts and
minds and thoughts today
and we're joined today
by NHS and social Care staff from across
the United Kingdom
including GPS nurses
midwives
ambulance staff mental health staff and
those providing social care and support
in the community and also by patient
Representatives
we're also thankful for those joining us
online today
we're here today
to thank and honor our Health and Social
Care staff for their sacrifice
commitment and courage in the face of
adversity and to say we won't ever
forget what you have done for us
in a moment a bell will signal the
beginning of a minute silence which will
conclude by performance from Alex
[Music]
foreign
that you still love me somehow
[Music]
I have to believe that a life that
meanings
[Music]
that I
make smaller differences somewhere
foreign
[Music]
that I am useful here
sometimes
that I make smaller differences
somewhere
I have to believe that I need to stay
for
sometimes
teaches me something
so that I can meet you again
somewhere
[Music]
Alex thank you for that beautiful piece
of music
it is so difficult to try and find
meaning in all of our multi-faceted
aspects of loss that we've experienced
and thank you for coming and bringing
that for us today thank you
the themes of our service today are lost
togetherness and Thanksgiving
for 75 years of care
we're also here to honor what it takes
what it takes to be a Health and Social
care worker
the dedication the commitment the
Courage the care the sacrifices
especially in these challenging times
we're here to honor and reflect on the
tragic loss of friends and families and
colleagues
we're also here to acknowledge the
losses and challenges of mental health
pressures experienced by health
care and social Care staff who are
serving Us in this unique moment in
history
these are difficult days
we are also here to give thanks and
celebrate the togetherness
the solidarity amongst Health and Social
care colleagues and the support that
they have given to each other and for us
the way staff have cared for each other
during these difficult times and cared
for others
their resourcefulness resilience and
commitment has been an inspiration to us
and we hugely value the cost that has
been given as they have served us so
Faithfully
that costs and loss has been felt on so
many levels
Healthcare staff across the last 75
years have been driven by their
commitment to care for others before
themselves
and in these challenging times
they have sacrificed their mental and
physical health
many staff
have very sadly paid the ultimate
sacrifice
with their lives
in introducing all of our wonderful
speakers and music today
to bring that inspiring and reassuring
comfort
I will be led with Mo bean and Sham
co-chaplings at Birmingham Women's and
Children's Hospital multi-faith and
belief team
I'm from David a chaplain at University
Hospitals Derby and Burton NHS Trust
all of whom have been
in covid and before involved in
supporting struggling and bereaved
families in the NHS
thank you
first we will hear a poem by Kate Fox
Robinson
these walls are Witness
then a testimonial from Karen Bonner
Chief nurse for buckinghamshire Health
Trust before Alex sings for us again
our poems will be read by Rachel Carter
director of Midwifery deputy chief nurse
Birmingham Women's and Children's NHS
Foundation Trust
Johnny Shaw head of trust charity at
Sandwell and West Birmingham NHS Trust
and Heather Petz associate director of
nursing Birmingham Women's and
Children's NHS Foundation Trust
just along the way these walls watch
intently as ordinary fragile lives are
pushed to the limits by professions
which once made their hearts sing now
just trying to make ends meet
but with so much dependent on their
every move
these walls are witness to slumped
shoulders over half drunk Cups of Tea
heads in hands lifted briefly only by
kisses flown through interior windows
from fellow workers
passing the Baton shift to shift in an
endless cycle of extraordinary intense
care
these Dependable walls witnessed to the
flow of movement of repeated footfall
the rise and fall of imperceptible
movements Hearts try to hold inside
just along the way
these walls though still full of photos
are Witness
to a new found emptiness
within Echoes of memories
beds
that no one is coming home to
and left unheld
the soft heads to plant kisses upon
gone now
the space
silent
full only of absences
these walls expand around loneliness
that will not be contained
just along the way these walls are thick
with grief
sorrow rolls down the pale yellow paint
pain reverberates through every single
streak
these wolves are saturated breaking open
from the inside out
these walls hold the horrors of the
world witness to the darkness listener
to the howling
wrenching cries hearing the most
devastating things in the world
and the most beautiful love that is
poured out in words in tears in kisses
on cold foreheads
in dreams lying shattered shards of
glass under tender feet
they tread softly here
take shaky sweaty hands lead them where
they do not want to go
and as the mourners leave these walls
feel exhausted faces pressed against the
coolness of their paint
trying to absorb their distress
heads resting briefly
before Rising again to meet other lives
waiting to be walked inside these walls
thank you
good morning
hello my name is Karen Bonner
I was really lucky I knew really early
on what I wanted to do with my life
I would become a nurse
and today my career has far superseded
my childhood aspirations
with over 25 years of experience behind
me
these experiences both positive and
negative have shaped me
and as a black senior nurse I recognize
the struggle that people of difference
have in their leadership Journey
on the 30th of March 2020 I began as
Chief nurse at buckinghamshire
Healthcare NHS Trust
at the time I became one of 10 black
Asian or ethnic nurses working at
executive level within the NHS
but I didn't know I was going to start
my job at the beginning of a global
pandemic
nothing could quite prepare me or my
colleagues for what we're about to face
working with this in this profession
comes with great privilege but great
responsibility
the demand on nurses and midwives is
extraordinary
and as caregivers we spend our time
putting our patients first
the pandemic brought an increased risk
to the public but to healthcare workers
alike and many nurses and midwives
didn't sign up to put their lives at
risk in the name of the GT but that's
what they did
it was mentally demanding it was
physically demanding
working in the most challenging
circumstances
I experienced a roller coaster of
emotions both highs and lows
kobit 19 Shone the light on the health
inequalities
with disproportionate impact on black
and Asian people
10 weeks into my role the worst
imaginable thing happened
I lost one of my colleagues a healthcare
support worker to covert 19.
he was being looked after in our
Intensive Care Unit by his colleagues
his name was June taray
and we felt that loss throughout the
organization
as it sent shock waves
through our teams as we realized this
virus had no boundaries
I too experience the personal loss A
friend of mine died he was 47.
on the 7th of May 2020
I was heartbroken
we all were
every day I'm saddened by the loss of
life and I'm reminded every day of the
pain
that every one of us have experienced
this heartbreak has felt so deeply by
all of us during the pandemic and it's a
pain that we will never ever forget
the responsibility for my team weighed
really heavily
but it was standing shoulder to shoulder
with my colleagues where we found our
strengths
19 pandemic brought out the best in
Health and Social Care staff
we will work together common purpose
going above and beyond
individuals were outstanding in their
practice
ready to serve as we fought off this
unknown enemy
today and every day I'm grateful for
every one of my colleagues both past and
present
and the compassion they give
and I want to say thank you
to all the courageous tenacious kind
people that make the NHS what it is
whatever we Face we can take pride in
our strength in tackling every challenge
as one
[Music]
does
I am not there
I do not sleep
I am a thousand wins that
blow
I am the softly falling snow
[Music]
I am the gentle Shahs Of Rain I am the
fields of
ripening Grace
I am in the morning
[Music]
I am the Starshine of the night
I am in every everything
I am instead foreign
[Music]
do not stand at my grave and we
I am not
please
I did not die
thank you Alex
for that moving performance
before the laying of our reads we will
hear a further personal experience of
the effects of
caring during covid-19
written by Karina garam
a paramedic from West Midlands Ambulance
Service
and today the read by Sarah Lawson
I used to be an auxiliary nurse at Queen
Elizabeth Hospital Birmingham one night
shift after a very long tough shift I
looked out from a High Street high-rise
window saw a yellow box in the distance
lights flashing driving through the
streets it was in that moment that I
knew my true calling was to become a
paramedic
we are the first Port of Call in
life-altering moments at the core of our
hearts and job is the passion for
helping people
we provide Comfort on people's worst
days but also on their best days
delivering babies bringing life into the
world it is a privilege to do it all
I began my journey in March 2020 holding
a lot of personal grief I had just lost
my nan in February and then locked down
began none of us knew what we were
facing we were walking into the unknown
for the first time our jobs felt scary
we could catch the virus ourselves or
pass it on to our loved ones but we
carried on we had to my mum was sheiling
shielding and I had a young family I was
so afraid of bringing the virus home I
remember walking through the door to my
children having quickly say don't touch
me I have to change my clothes clean
everything before we could cautiously
cautiously be near each other
many of the restrictions we had to use
were heartbreaking I'll never forget
caring for a poorly baby I could only
allow a mom in the ambulance I had to
almost close the door on the baby's dad
thinking this is his baby too what
happens next seen the mum facing such a
terrifying moment alone was gutter
wrenching equally we were called to a
son who had dialed 999 for his elderly
mum she had covered and was really
unwell
we knew she probably wouldn't make it I
had to say to him do you want to say
goodbye
and then we closed the ambulance doors
and that was almost the last time that
he saw her alive it was devastating
I don't think I could have done it
without my colleagues it's hard to
describe the relationships between
ambulance staff Through The Dark Times
we'd held each other up sometimes just a
look was enough
we all knew
we could have the worst job ever but
together we will get through it we
aren't just a crew why are each other's
support
but it's not just each other we support
our patients too sometimes we're like
swans calm on the surface but paddling
furiously underneath our stability and
resilience means we can be the rock they
need in moments of turmoil our warmth
reissue is then that they're going to be
looked after I feel truly blessed to do
my job blessed to be part of this team
and be there for every patient who calls
on us thank you
foreign
thank you Sarah for reading Karina
testimono
shared so poignantly and captured
many of our experiences during the past
three years
of weaves will now be laid by staff
representing different caring
professions
patience those disproportionately
affected by covid
devolved Nations volunteers and to
reflect on global loss
during this time the lewisham and
Greenwich NHS choir
will sing again
[Music]
foreign
Bridge Over Troubled Water
please
[Music]
spring
foreign
[Music]
God
my friends
[Music]
I will name
foreign
[Music]
if you leave
foreign
[Music]
as we have sought to honor the many
types of losses and sacrifices made by
so many during the past three years
it is also important for us to
acknowledge the sport and solidarity
staff have generously offered each other
we will now hear from Max Usman
community mental health nurse
practitioner at Lancashire and South
Cumbria Foundation Trust
good morning everybody
my name is
Maxwell husseman
and I'm especially very honored to be
here today and
I'm on my 51st year as a nurse
in the NHS and I stand in front of you
as a proudest Nerf on Earth
when I was age 19 I came to England from
Mauritius
I do consider myself as one of those
Windrush generation of nurses of the 70s
but I didn't come over there when was
the boat I came by an airplane
and
it was a culture shock when I came here
to adapt to the food
environment
and the culture
my English was very poor at the point
then
and when I began the career as well
I didn't have much knowledge about the
body itself I knew where my heart was
that was about it
and now what it meant to be a nurse I
didn't have a clue
I remember the
the my watch sister said to me Mr Usman
you will never make a nurse and that
does resonate with me to this day
because I was always running like a
headless chicken around the world not
knowing what to do we're very frightened
and and again arriving here you know
I didn't have no confidence at all to
challenge different views and perception
I used to run out of the office when the
phone rang because I couldn't really
take all these blood samples that they
were giving me the results of and so I
just had to go and hide in this loose
and and bear clean bad pants most of the
time and that's why we spent also our
days cleaning beds and you know toilets
in those days and I was warned that
you're going to go to England and do
those jobs but I didn't do it
and the Project's moment was when in my
life was when I did qualified
as a state registeredness and not many
of us did that it was one of the few was
supposed to get the rmn most of my
colleagues got the scn which was the two
years course but I was given the free
year we was kind of a little bit above
the scn level so and everybody said to
me how come you you got to do the SR and
we all did scn but nevertheless I do
remember being that proud nurse I got
the ticket now I thought and I was I was
really confident to wear my uniform
and I did wait it was really Pride I
remember having these blue epaulets and
white unique uh and and kind of walking
down the ward like like a wheel like
like a peacock chest out and walking
down look at me I've arrived
but
and after that I did become quite
inquisitive and I was hungry for
knowledge I didn't have much at the time
and I had to overcome a lot of obstacles
to flourish and shine and eventually I
became a deputy director of nursing
mental health nursing that is and
nowadays I work
as a nurse in Lancashire in South
Cumbria and it's his choice
I get to know and connect with my
patients and they connect with me we
have beautiful interaction daily
and and and that's what you know gave me
steps in my you know when I wake up I'm
looking forward to that to this day
for me care comes from the heart it's
about being holistic
giving a bit of myself always self
disclose when I work and people say you
know I can go for a part with you and
things like that you're a cool guy
and and I like to empower my patients
really because my patients are my equal
and they're really my Ally
and it's about them and it's not about
them and us you we talk about
but there's only one of us we're all
part of that Humanity of Oneness
and really nurses they they get to know
their patient the way no one else does
nursing is still really undervalued I
didn't want to be a nurse when I started
my journey I wanted to be a doctor
because we put more value to
to being a doctor and everybody when I
start my conversation I'm Max I'm a
nurse and it's usually down the line it
says yes doctor
I know what nursing is about I'm the
proudest nurses I say so I try to
remember to people because in their head
I can't be I can't be a nurse my
granddaughter came to me she's five and
said Grandad you can't be a doctor and
you can't be a nurse I said why not ivy
this is you're a man So eventually she
came back to me and said yes Granddad
you can be a dog you can be a nurse and
I can be a doctor that was quite a
changing moment of stereotype and
attitude and that's again that broadest
moment of my life I've said that you
know we need to write a book there's a
book about my dad is a nurse but I've
said to the people about doing that I
want to say my granddad is a nurse
because I'm a Granddad now so I think I
need to change that perception of who we
are and what we can do now again when
the you know as I say that and the value
I want to bridge that gender gap well I
know it's very female orientated but
having a some emails I mean brownness
but we are good nurses just as a female
nurses we can't have more of us so I do
a little bit of that to promote the
diversity of nursing as well you've got
Chief nurse you've got the roof maybe
the top of our profession we're very
proud of at a moment with a a few
minutes ago that was a and she told me
to stand between my feet apart which is
quite good that's what I'm doing so I've
learned something already
you know during that pandemic we had a
weird kind of uh we carry the big load
there was guilt and anger we were all in
it together you know I had to work from
home put a number of months to protect
myself from the virus and with the
virtual work we did we couldn't connect
with our patients and colleagues I found
myself feeling really lonely detached
and isolated and it and it felt really
hard
but it created a big internal struggle
for me
I could stop thinking about the staff in
the itu wars would be dealing with so
Much Death I go to bed thinking about
that I wake up thinking about that the
moral injury was palpable and it was
really hurting me but I had to be there
to be with my colleagues
however for the NHS Hub I find comfort
and there I started you know our
well-being became a priority which we
use and I think that was the kind of
because before that well-being was just
said well-being of stuff but this at
that moment we needed that then we felt
that was there for us which was very
helpful for me
and the pandemic I was able to work
continuously for two years without
sickness
I was a lucky one because I didn't feel
sick you know and I'm still going now
and I've you know I've I've got more to
give people ask me why do I stay working
for 51 years I'm 70 or 70 last Saturday
but nursing who I am
this is what drives me I find purpose in
work I enjoy my work and and to be
honest I do a Friday feelings Monday
mornings not many people can say that
along the way I've learned the impact we
can all have on others I continue to
learn and improve daily I'm going to
revalidate in December and Compass our
compassion really can tell our
compassion can and does change people's
lives and that's I do believe in that
so to my patients and colleagues I say
thank you
for all you do we must Inspire each
other
keep going because it's our solidarity
that gives me so much hope for the
future thank you
thank you very much Max
for that inspiration down edges
we now have a special commissioned poem
for today
boys social care as a Chaplain
David Buck
if there is one thing that Healthcare
professionals represent them that is
Hope
hope in times open and hardship
hope through acts of kindness
the way they care and heal
we pay tribute and honor those Health
and Care staff
who continue to embody
hope through what they do
this is read by Adam Weston
a paramedic
at West Midlands Ambulance Service
thank you
hope
by David Burke
something compels me
makes me say
yes
yes to purpose to being
to life
and where there is life they say there
is hope
despite all
there is life here
life in doing
listening
caring
alongside
with and in knowing Goods will happen
because it can
and like a thing of beauty
it is a captivating thing this hope
that compels me
makes me say
yes
okay
thank you Adam
you will now hear from Heidi Thomas Obe
the writer and creator of Call the
Midwife
and a screenwriter of the forthcoming
Hallelujah
who will share
specially written dedication to NHS
staff
in its 75th anniversary year
hello
my name is Heidi and I am not a nurse a
doctor or a midwife
I'm a screenwriter and I write medical
dramas
the blood I work with is fake blood and
at my place of work when we say cut we
aren't referring to a wound or an
incision but simply telling the cameras
to stop rolling
what we do is make believe while the NHS
deals with life's deepest realities
today I stand here with you and I am
completely humbled
but one way or another whether we work
for it or not we all represent the
National Health Service
we literally carry it in our bones
it received us at Birth it vaccinated us
provided vitamins it has been there for
our playground Falls and our traffic
accidents our appendectomies and our
cancers
it will be there when we are old
but if some of us take from the system
all our lives others give regardless of
the cost
the dedication that the NHS workers
touches millions of us
if it feels as though that goes
unacknowledged I as one member of One
ordinary family would like to say this
to the registrar summoned from his bed
at 4 00 am to perform the seven hour
operation that saved my life I will not
forget you
to the radiographers who treated my
confused 99 year old grandmother for
cancer whilst holding her hand and
calling her by her name I will not
forget you
to the gray-haired nurse who calmed my
terrified little boy by asking what he
was most afraid of listening to the
answer and reassuring him I will not
forget you
and to the paramedics who spent two
hours stabilizing my mother so that she
could make her final journey to hospital
in an ambulance
I will not forget you
one of you even kissed her on the cheek
before you parted company in recess and
I will remember that until the day I die
but what happens to the people whose
work is other people's lives
cares for them and how do they grieve
remembrance is more than not forgetting
it is a commitment to gratitude and
active ongoing respect for the workers
who were there and will be there at our
frailst moments and in our darkest hours
there are nurses in my family and during
covid I saw the wheels the PPE left on
their lovely faces
I saw their exhaustion their
determination their desire to do what
good they could
and I still see all of those qualities
in action now as the world picks up the
pieces as the NHS fights on
the National Health Service is the
greatest idea this country ever had and
the finest story it has ever told about
itself
but it has been written not in words but
by the actions of its workers
every shift every Handover every
handheld the story continues because it
must
and it is a masterpiece
I bow before it the people should bow
before it the powers that be should bow
before it and give thanks to everyone
who makes it possible
Heidi thank you for such a personal and
professional affirmation of all that we
seek to do thank you very very much
and so before our wonderful choir
sing us out and remind us of what we
take forward
we come and bring together all that has
been shared today
as we have gone on that journey of
reflecting on all the different types of
loss that we've experienced in the last
three years and in the last 75 years of
the NHS
of all those different ways in which we
have suffered
with calm and held that together
with the hope
with the Gratitude with the Thanksgiving
and the togetherness
that sustains Us in going forward
and so thank you to all those who have
helped put to daily together and
contributed thank you very much
my hope our hope our hope together
is that you have found some heart ease
in that you have been acknowledged in
all
that you have given in all that it takes
to do the job that you do
we hope that we have done Justice to
acknowledge the current pressures and
the losses that you and others have
faced
you are busier than ever yet you
continue to put patience before
yourselves you are more tired than ever
but you keep going despite the
exhaustion that you feel
we promise you we will not forget your
commitment and sacrifices that you and
your colleagues have made over the last
75 years and continue to make every day
today we have heard of the great support
of colleagues that we give each other
and celebrating that togetherness
the mutuality the support and strength
that we gain from colleagues
the precious moments of friendship and
the hope that can stem from that
we build solidarity together
as we bring our strengths and weaknesses
as one
and we can be confident
that as we go forward
we will continue to affirm and sustain
Social and Health Care staff
in this ongoing multi-faceted losses and
support
that support
from those who care
who are thankful
from a grateful public
for us even in our darkest moments
when we feel that all that we have done
may have not been seen acknowledged or
forgotten
we take forward this
we have not been forgotten
we will not be forgotten
others will not forget
and we will celebrate all that you stand
for
thank you
thank you for being there
for all of us
[Music]
foreign
somebody to lean on
[Music]
that you'll understand
[Applause]
[Music]
people belongs
there is
[Music]
you just call me
Lean on Me
When You're Not Strong
I'll be
over I'll help you carry on
any
[Music]
teachers
thank you
[Music]